let me begin by thanking the organizers
of this conference for what has been a
fascinating day of presentations thus
far I don't know whether I can keep that
record going but we'll see I feel like I
need to begin i'm going to ask jana not
to count what I'm about to say against
my time so I feel like I need to
introduce myself as was noted my name is
David Campbell and I teach at the
University of Notre Dame which means
that audiences often think that I am
Catholic but I am NOT and I think I can
safely say to this crowd that I'm a
Mormon but you know when your political
scientists this occupational hazard of
my profession is that your occasionally
asked to speak about elections and so a
few years ago I was asked to sit on a
round table at Notre Dame on Catholics
in American politics so I've disclosed
one thing about my biography to you let
me disclose another i'm actually not an
American I'm a Canadian a I didn't get
quite the response from that one that I
did from the Mormon disclosure but
anyway I went to this little round table
you know the sort of thing colleges do
and I said to the group of students
assemble their well you know the thing
you should know about me is that I'm
neither an American nor am I Catholic
but I'm going to tell you about
Catholics in American politics and so if
you want to hear what a non-catholic
non-american has to say about that
subject stick around hahaha that's my
excuse for a joke well the next day in
the campus newspaper the front page
story went like this yesterday professor
David Campbell neither a Catholic nor an
American said that i deducted again so I
feel like I'm always the fish out of
water and maybe even more so today
because unlike the others who have
spoken today I am NOT a historian I'm a
political scientist so what I'm going to
be talking about today is some data from
contemporary Mormons so these are going
to be quantitative empirical results
from two national surveys one of the
American population in general
it's called the faith matters survey it
was the source of data for a book that i
published a little over a year ago with
robert putnam of harvard entitled
American grace how religion divides and
unites us available in paperback in just
two weeks what you should know about
this survey is that it was big and that
it is representative of the entire
American population which includes of
course Mormons but it means that i can
compare mormons to members of other
religions and i'll be doing that and
even though our book actually deals with
data from two thousand six and two
thousand seven we've actually gone back
to those same people we've interviewed
them again in 2011 that's the data that
i'll be showing here today i'll also be
showing you for the first time ever you
are the first audience ever to hear
about these results i'll be reporting on
what we call the peculiar people survey
this was a study done of just mormons i
did it in collaboration with john green
at the University of Akron and Quinn
Monson at Brigham Young University this
is a representative sample of 500
Mormons a survey conducted just a few
weeks ago beginning in the end of
December spanning into early January and
and even though I will not hear be
talking about the data from this recent
survey that the pew forum on religion
and public life did on Mormons both John
Green and I were consultants on that
study and I can assure you that the
results from the study i'm going to be
showing you today actually match the pew
results exactly in fact it's almost
uncanny how close we are to results that
they have let me begin with just sort of
a whimsical observation a question we
threw in our survey that we thought was
kind of fun we asked again this is
Mormons themselves do you agree with the
statement that Mormons are correctly
described by the biblical phrase quote a
peculiar people and as you can see
roughly eighty percent of Mormons are
more than happy to refer to themselves
as peculiar so for those who may not be
LDS in the audience I assure you that
when we refer to Mormons as a
people we are not saying anything
pejorative if anything Mormons love it
so we'll be talking about that what I
want to talk about today though is
Mormon political mobilization the
factors that lead to it and I'd like to
introduce a metaphor the metaphor is
that Mormons are like dry kindling what
do I mean by that well it means that
Mormons can be rapidly and intensely
mobilized into politics in the same way
that if you drop a match on to kindling
it can ignite quickly however this only
happens rarely indeed it can only happen
rarely because if these efforts at
mobilization were frequent they would
cease to be effective there are some
pre-existing conditions for the
political mobilization of Mormons
Mormons are and this is how I'll
structure the rest of my remarks wormans
are conservative I'll show you some
evidence about that presumably that's
not going to come as a shock to anyone
in the crowd but i'll show you some
evidence on it nonetheless however
Mormons are also distinctive in some
very interesting ways so they do not
look like all the other conservatives in
American on a few issues they're very
distinctive and I want to talk about
that Mormons are also very active the
very active in their faith and I'll show
you some evidence on that and that's
important because activity in a church
and this is not unique to Mormonism it's
true religions in general activity in a
church lays the groundwork it
establishes the network's it gives
people the skills that enables them to
be mobilized into politics it turns out
that trying to get a large number of
people out to a park to clean it up
looks a lot like trying to get a large
number of people out to a caucus or to
put lawn signs on people's yards during
a political campaign and finally Mormons
are cohesive which is an important
element also of understanding the
political profile of American Mormon so
let me just begin with the fact that
Mormons are conservative something i'm
going to bed is not terribly
controversial but nonetheless
worth noting what you're looking at is a
slide that compares various religious
traditions in America Mormons at one end
it also includes evangelicals and black
Protestants and Catholics and Jews and
this is just the percentage Republican
and as you can see from this slide
Mormons are the most Republican
religious group in the country the edge
out evangelicals by just hair it's also
true that Mormons are the most likely to
describe themselves as very conservative
we gave people a range of options but I
want to note that even though they are
the most likely to describe themselves
as very conservative it's not everyone
okay now if we added in the percentage
you just say plain old conservative
that's going to be a higher bar but I
focus on the very conservative just to
make the point and this will be a
recurring theme throughout these remarks
there is a strain of moderation and
pragmatism within the Mormon population
that should not be lost in any
discussion of their political profile
okay so there's some evidence Mormons or
conservative no shock but let me show
you some ways in which Mormons are
distinctive well their distinctive in a
conservative way on some issues so this
shows you the percentage of Americans
who say it is better for a household if
the wife stays home and the husband is
the breadwinner the other option being
that the husband and wife both work and
share responsibilities at home so this
is the percentage who choose the more
conservative a traditionalist option
that's better if women do not work and
you can see that Mormons are very
distinctive on this issue the Mormons
are much more likely to say that it is
better that doesn't mean that they
themselves necessarily have that family
relationship this question asked them
what do you think is the ideal situation
and Mormons are the most likely to say
that it's well it's better actually for
everyone involved if women don't work so
there's a conservative example of how
Mormons are distinctive another one that
I suppose you'd characterize as
conservative certainly as interesting is
on our survey of just Mormons now we
asked a question of whether you believe
the United States Constitution is
divinely inspired and we're showing you
the percentage who strongly
agree agree disagree or strongly
disagree with that statement and you can
see that seventy percent of America of
American Mormons believe that the u.s.
constant they strongly agree that the US
Constitution is divinely inspired adding
the twenty percent who agree and you get
near unanimity on that question that
sort of fits in with Professor Barlow's
remarks just a few minutes ago okay so
those are two examples of these are ways
that we see the distinctiveness of
Mormons on the right but it turns out
that on some other issues Mormons are
distinctive in ways that do not
necessarily fall in line with the right
wing of American politics on immigration
Mormons while not the most Pro immigrant
group in America are far more supportive
of positive toward immigrants than our
other conservative groups like the
evangelicals so this question again
comes from our survey of the entire US
population we asked people to make a
trade off do you think it's better for
us to increase immigration or should we
should we decrease it this is shows you
the percentage who say that immigration
should be increased it's interesting
that none of these numbers are terribly
high but Mormons are far more likely
than evangelicals to say that yes we
should have more immigration and the
only group that they sort of come close
to our really Jews Jews are a little
more likely to support immigration and
but of course politically Jews look a
lot different in many other respects
from Mormons I'll skip over that more
evidence that Mormons are conflicted on
immigration on our survey of Mormons
only we asked Mormons to place
themselves on a continuum so they could
either say that well immigrant strength
in our country they could say that
immigrants are a burden or they could
pick some point in between and this
shows you that well it's kind of an even
mix across those four options it's not
like Mormons cluster on one side of that
question versus another which suggests
that when it comes to immigration
Mormons are conflicted perhaps I'll skip
over that one
on the question of gay marriage this is
one that is of interest to a lot of
audiences given the LDS Church's
high-profile on the question of same-sex
marriage we asked again on the survey of
all Americans a question that allowed
people to express their opinion on gay
marriage with a variety of options so
you could say that you didn't think
there should be gay marriage or civil
unions that is no legal recognition of
homosexual relationships you could take
a middle ground and say no to gay
marriage but yes to civil unions or you
could say yes to gay marriage okay that
makes sense if you add up the two
categories that oppose gay marriage that
is no gay marriage no civil unions plus
those who say no gay marriage but civil
unions are okay Mormons are the most
likely to oppose gay marriage okay so by
that definition Mormons are the most
likely that's the overall height of the
bar you're looking at but that white
part of the bar versus the purplish part
of the bar the white part of the bar
that's the percentage of Mormons who say
that civil unions are okay look how
large that is that's a big chunk of the
Mormon population more evidence that
actually the plurality of Mormons
support the middle ground on gay
marriage comes from our survey of
Mormons only we asked exactly the same
question and as you can see it's the
middle category we're Mormons are most
likely to cluster this is evidence again
of that moderate pragmatic element of
Mormonism on abortion Mormons are also
very distinctive if you characterize
someone who opposes abortion under all
circumstances or opposes abortion except
for cases of rape incest and where the
mother's health is in jeopardy okay and
that's actually the when most
politicians describe themselves as
pro-life that's what most of them would
would take as their position that they
would permit abortion under the what are
sometimes called the big three
exceptions if you add those two together
Mormons look pretty pro-life right so
there are about on par with evangelicals
they're about on
par with Catholics but note the gehen
the difference between the white chunk
of the Bar and the purplish part of the
bar the purplish part of the bar is the
percentage of Mormons or any other group
who oppose abortion under all
circumstances that is the most ardent
fervent pro-life stance very very few
Mormons take that position most Mormons
say well abortion in general ought not
to be permitted but I'm willing to allow
it in the cases of rape incest and where
the mother's health is in jeopardy now
why would Mormons say that it's because
that is the actual I'm not going to say
doctrine of the church but it's
definitely the practice of the church or
the policy of the church is not actually
to take the hardline pro-life position
like for example the Catholic Church
does but instead to generally discourage
strongly abortion but nonetheless
permitted in a few extreme cases just to
show you some more evidence of this this
is the percentage of Mormons who when
given a series of circumstances would
you permit abortion under this
circumstance under that circumstance who
say that abortion should be permitted
where the mother's health is in jeopardy
or when the pregnancy as a result of
rape it's almost unanimous almost all
Mormons agree that abortion should be
permitted under those circumstances and
I just wanted to compare Mormons to the
black bars the US population in general
the Graybar Catholics the white bar
evangelicals on those two circumstances
Mormons are actually more willing to
approve of abortion then the population
as a whole and certainly more than
Catholics or evangelicals but not under
any other circumstances you asked about
whether there's a serious defect with
the baby about thirty percent of Mormons
say well okay will accept abortion under
those circumstances ask should abortion
be permitted if the woman is poor that's
the mark is low income very few Mormons
would approve of abortion in that
circumstance what if the woman just
wants abortion for any reason no what if
she's married but doesn't
any more children no or very few what if
the woman isn't married that's a reason
for wanting an abortion and in all those
cases we see that Mormons are less
likely to approve of abortion than are
the US population as a whole Catholics
or evangelicals that's all evidence that
Mormons are distinctive in some
interesting ways Mormons are also highly
active how active are they this graph
shows you the percentage of Mormons who
attend church weekly that's the purplish
bar pray daily or read read scripture
daily and it compares the percentage of
Mormons who do those things versus other
groups and you can see that in every
case Mormons are more likely to attend
church to pray and to read scriptures
daily this extends to all sorts of
things I'm running short on time so I
won't be able to go into all that much
detail but it's true for religious
volunteering that is in Mormon parlance
holding a calling it's true for
financial contributions to the church
tithing Mormons are just more likely to
do this stuff than our members of any
other religious tradition in America
however and this is important to note
under normal circumstances Mormons
participate in politics at about the
same rate as everyone else this graph
shows you a number of forms of political
activity whether you vote in local
elections whether you've contacted
government whether you've attended a
rally and Mormons don't bleep out as
being especially high or especially low
so a lot of community involvement not
just in their church but also in their
communities that's important to note but
not a particularly distinctive group
politically when it comes to their
activity so they're out there they're
doing stuff but not necessarily more
than other groups under normal
circumstances Mormons are cohesive lots
of evidence of this Mormons are the most
religiously insular group in the country
much more likely to have neighbors
friends family members of the same
religion
graph compares Mormons to other groups
on a measure of religious bonding we
call it about Putnam and I use you can
see if you're above that white bar
you're above the national average in
your bonding and Mormons well they're
not only above the bar they're really
close to black Protestants and they fall
a little behind Latino Catholics let me
repeat that blacks and Latinos bond you
can perhaps appreciate why an ethnic
group would do that at almost the same
rate that Mormons do a religion that is
not ethnic in its composition
let me just give you another example of
Mormon bonding and I love to point this
out to audiences on our big study that
Bob Putnam and I did we ask people how
they perceive other religions we use a
thing called the feeling thermometer
this is a score between 0 and 100 how
you feel about another religious group
the white bar is how a group Mormons
Jews Catholics how they feel about
themselves the purplish bar is everybody
else feels about them for no group is
there a wider division between how the
rest of the country sees the Mormons are
not the least popular group in America
if you're a Mormon right now you should
be saying thank goodness for the Muslims
and the atheists but Mormons like
themselves more than any other group
likes themselves more than Jews like
Jews more than blacks like blacks more
than Latinos like latinos that's a
remarkable fact but are Mormons
mobilized into politics remember I said
their general level of political
activity actually pretty low and when
you ask a question about whether you get
politics at church and again to a Mormon
audience what I'm about to say
completely non-controversial to a
non-mormon audience I have been hammered
on this again and again people just
don't want to believe it well if you ask
do you hear about politics at church or
at least over the pulpit Mormons say no
no religion has all that much religion
injured or politics at church Mormons
have virtually none at least official
politicking over the pulpit or voter
guides those sorts of things they will
talk about it they talk about it a
church a little bit they talk about it
in conversations outside of church
that's what you're looking at in the
various bars here so we've got sacrament
meeting that's the church meetings that
are held on Sundays virtually no
politics the next is whether the lessons
that are taught do they mention politics
is a little bit more about conversations
in church a little bit more
conversations outside of church sure
there's a lot and those conversations
are largely going to skew in the
conservative direction okay that lays
out the groundwork for what I want to
this dry kindling metaphor dropped the
match Mormons get mobilized when does
that happen when do all those conditions
kick in the fact that they're cohesive
and their distinctive and they have
these skills this experience and getting
involved in stuff when does that matter
politically well Quinn monster and I
have published a paper in which we argue
that Mormons follow their leaders when
two conditions hold when LDS officials
explicitly endorse an issue they make it
clear that it matters to church
leadership and when they present a
united front that is all the general
authorities agree now to contemporary
Mormons the second one seems like kind
of a dumb thing to say well of course
the general authorities agree right well
they do today but they didn't in the
past we already heard that remember Jan
ships told us that in 1936 Hebrew Jay
grant told Mormons in Utah don't vote
Roosevelt's and what did the Mormons do
they went ahead and voted for Roosevelt
they did the same thing on prohibition
he said let's keep prohibition and
Mormon said yeah that's not but today of
course it's a different world and so
with if the church speaks out of a
political issue it does so with a united
front it's important to note however
that the church only does this early has
done it in the last 40 or so years on
ballot propositions nonpartisan
elections so I'm just going to show you
homie Becca one piece of evidence that
these things matter it matters when
church leaders speak out on issues and
we're going to actually use a hard
example so on this survey we did a
little experiment we separated out our
respondents randomly and some got this
statement some state and local
governments have provoked proposed laws
to prohibit discrimination and housing
and employment based on sexual
orientation some people oppose this idea
because they believe it would show
approval of homosexuality to what extent
do you favor or oppose a law to prohibit
discrimination in housing and employment
based on sexual orientation okay and
people could pick their position on a
scale of zero to 100 so you have these
two options and you had a little slider
and you could move it where you thought
your opinion then we gave another group
again randomly sampled
the same information so they got all the
same stuff but then we added this in
response to the debate on the issue the
church has issued the following and this
is a true statement we did not make this
up we actually pulled this from a
statement out of the LDS Public Affairs
Office quote the Church believes in
human dignity in treating others with
respect even when we disagree in fact
especially when we disagree and then
people were asked do you agree or
disagree with this anti-discrimination
statute does that make sense how that
worked okay then we gave them a specific
statement from the church again drawn
from church material the Church believes
human dignity in human dignity in
treating others with respect and in the
right of people to have a roof over
their heads and the right to work
without being discriminated against so
it's a more specific reference to the
issue at hand and the question is what
happens to Mormons opinions right you
would not normally expect the highly
conservative group like this to be all
that sympathetic to an
anti-discrimination statute that deals
with homosexuality that would be our
prior that's what you would expect right
but we know the church has actually been
involved in this issue at least in the
salt lake city area and the church has
actually said now we're okay with non
discrimination statute so we wanted to
see can we move Mormon opinion by
telling them that their church has taken
a position that you might characterize
as more liberal even can I say that then
where you'd expect your modal Mormon to
be here's what happens the baseline the
first bar those are people who just are
asked what's your opinion on this issue
and they're about in the middle so again
there's that moderation that we see
those who hear the general LDS statement
they're a little more likely to support
this law okay but those who hear the
specific LDS statement the one that said
actually you know what we don't like
discrimination in housing and jobs those
folks are much more likely to now
support the law the white border
signifies that that's a statistically
significant difference from the baseline
category in other words Mormon opinion
can move on this issue and this is a
tough case right this is a case where
people are being asked to essentially
move against their natural
political inclinations and we see
evidence that it works now is this the
same thing as saying that these folks
would go out and campaign on behalf of
this issue that's a harder thing to say
but I am willing to put forward that the
conditions that we describe for the dry
kindling to work are potentially
operational on multiple issues not just
on the issue of gay marriage that's not
a prediction that we will see them
happen often but it is a prediction that
if you were to see LDS leaders speak out
on an issue that they have a lot to work
with in the Mormon population but it's a
double-edged sword because use the
kindling once and it's extinguished and
you have to wait for it to build up
again so my final point I'll just skip
ahead we had other experiments but I
won't go into them here let me go back
to my initial question are Mormons a
peculiar people well the answer is yes
but not always in the way you think
thank you very much
well thanks to our presenters who did
such a great job of getting us caught up
to our proposed timeline we still have
about 10 minutes for questions and if I
could just exert a moment of executive
privilege I have a question for you Phil
just this week I came across an article
that you wrote i think it was in
religion and american culture a while
ago about Mitt Romney and your personal
interaction with him which has a very
modest person I noticed you would not
bring up here but you closed your paper
today discussing the importance of
character in politics how Romney's
character would inform his politics and
because that has been such a point of
well it's been a problematic point for
Romney with some accusations about
honesty about greed how would you assess
his character having served with him in
a bishopric many years ago and having
known him personally I'm just curious
hmm that sounds like a tender topic
today we should we should mention just
remind ourselves that i'm sure this
audience is not entirely obvious a
bishopric are the three people who lead
a ward or a congregation yeah so I was a
counselor to MIT when he was a bishop in
Cambridge back in the day and I never
saw anything in my personal dealings
with him that would separate him from
most other Mormon bishops in matters of
character if by character in that
question we mean integrity honesty
character can mean other things as I
tried to suggest in the paper like grit
or stubbornness or swimming up stream
toughness adventuresome nests those
sorts of traits but as far as having
integrity I've been aware of the
possibility the observations the
questions the assertions about changing
his positions over much and not really
standing for anything I'd have to let
him answer for himself as he has in
response I remember especially he is
grilling by TM Russert on meet the press
in the 2008 election and it explained
himself and that would be an example in
their archives of a place to go when you
have when the candidate has a full hour
to explain himself but in his private
behavior I saw only goodwill and honesty
that work didn't have any reason to
question that thank you so much for
letting me indulge that moment other
questions for our panelists yes will
well it's it's a nationally
representative sample so we did not
target any particular demographic within
the Mormon population if you want the I
won't go to too much technical detail
but in order to survey a small group
like this this was true actually of this
big pew survey that was recently done
you do have to pay some attention to
geographic clustering so there was a
when we were finding the Mormons to
interview we did account for the fact
that they happen to be concentrated in
the mountain west but then when we
report the results we also account for
the fact that we took that into account
when we first drew the sample in other
words what you're looking at is a
representative slice of the Mormon
population but and I will stress this a
self-identified Mormon population so if
you look carefully the numbers we have
and this is true for the Pew survey and
other surveys of Mormons church
attendance rates are reported
astronomically high level 70 75 percent
of these folks say that they attend
church on a weekly basis the members of
the LDS Church in the audience for
thinking i'm not sure that seventy-five
percent of my congregation is shown up
every sunday and that's because many of
the people who we might have on the
records of the church would not and
therefore are counted against those
attendance otisco phi themselves as
mormon when somebody calls them on the
phone or contacts them in some other way
and asks for their religion yes yeah and
that's what I mean this is literally
what I say is the first cut like I did
this on Tuesday but age differences are
one of the most interesting things we
want to look at within the Mormon
population because they're a lot of
generational differences yes in the
front row
well depends on so the question we
didn't hear it was should we expect to
see this dry kindling phenomenon occur
in support of the Romney candidacy you
wouldn't you wouldn't ok so you wouldn't
in the sense that what I was describing
would be top-down mobilization
encouraged by church leadership like for
example in the proposition 8 campaign in
California that we'll hear more about
from Joanna Brooks you will not see that
done by church leaders on behalf of Mitt
Romney I am willing to go on the record
with that one I'd swear swear on the
Bible and the Book of Mormon and the
pearl of great price and the doctor go
however those conditions that enable
Mormons to be mobilized that is the fact
that they work in these are the
tight-knit congregations and they do
lots of stuff together and they feel
that their distinctive and peculiar and
all of that would work to the benefit of
others not church leaders but others who
might want to tap into that energy on
behalf of the Romney candidacy so yes
and I suspect you're going to see that
tomorrow in the Nevada caucuses lots of
Mormons are going to show up and why is
that happening because elders quorum
presidents and bishops that as local
leaders are going to be calling up their
friends who are in the church and cetera
but that's a very different thing than
having the president of the LDS Church
say all right folks let's mobilize on
behalf of Mitt Romney that's that's not
going to happen yes
good question how does the church choose
its issues I wouldn't claim to to know
what goes on inside the the meetings of
the hearts or the souls of the General
Authorities of the church when they make
these decisions I will say that there
are a few issues historically that the
church has been quite interested in
obviously gay marriage but even on gay
marriage the church has been very
selective it was actually silent
essentially in 2004 when there were 13
ballot initiatives on same-sex marriage
including one in the state of Utah
church stayed pretty well silent they
did get involved in California I think
for radios and cratic reasons that
basically they felt they could make a
difference they care a lot about
gambling that doesn't get as much
attention but the church is actually on
a number of occasions worked on ballot
initiatives to either against gambling
or lotteries or those sorts of things
and then going way back the church has
been interested in alcohol policy I
haven't had a ballot proposition on that
a long time but that has been issue and
then should it should an immigration
issue come up particularly in states
where there's a concentration of Mormons
I wouldn't be surprised if that's one
where the church might also get involved
but they'll do so only selectively and
carefully these are pragmatic strategic
people they don't want to waste their
their resources we have two questions
here in the middle
right so this is my co-author Bob Putnam
I I wasn't here to hear what he said but
you know i render book together so i can
i can guess what he was saying which is
that among young Americans this is not
young mormons putting young among young
Americans you see this very interesting
divide y'all any aleek al them pro-life
on abortion perfectly fine with gay
marriage so they're moving in opposite
directions on the two issues that have
united the religious right it's not
actually the same with young Mormons so
young Mormons are going to look like all
Mormons in general on abortion right so
generally pro-life with the there okay
then that in a couple of exceptions gay
marriage is a little trickier so on gay
marriage young Mormons now they're
pretty conservative on gay rights
generally or sort of attitudes toward
homosexuality you're going to find a
real softening among young Mormons like
you would among young Millennials not
the same extent right so just like
attitudes towards gender roles in the
LDS population you could say are like 30
years behind or 40 years behind the rest
of the country young Mormons are
probably 10 or 20 years behind their
young peers and other religious groups
but still far more sympathetic to gays
than their parents or the grandparents
ever been doing Episcopal Church any
Episcopalians in the audience I'm a
Mormon fair to say that the
Episcopalians try to do a lot of
political mobilizations a pretty
political you know I actually think of
the Episcopalians as a terribly
political church but actually they are
how effective would you say Episcopalian
political mobilization is we're not
holding conferences fearing the
Episcopalians rising up and changing the
face of America yeah that's right they
work from the top ask any rabbi they'll
tell you the same things and synagogues
very politically active but on any given
issue they would have the same
difficulty mobilizing their members that
Mormons have getting people to volunteer
to come out to the boy scout camp why
because they asked about the Boy Scouts
all the time so it kind of takes on a
the flavor of something you can refuse
because it happens all the time politics
really rare and so when it happens it
catches the attention and I think
there's a recognition on the part of
church leaders that if they did it a lot
not only would it throw their tax-exempt
status into question it would deplete
the resource they have not actually I'm
sorry you look desperate max okay
quickly max your question
related to the change in the Church's
position to be the world it's a World
Church I'm curious about the
reorientation of American exceptionalism
have as a theological question for the
church just this morning is New York
Times article about how the churches to
the left and this is actually shown a
lot of the left of many visions of its
politician members Mitt Romney be much
more so I'm curious about the church
changing yeah there I think that would
be an increasing increasingly
interesting or compelling series of
fractures to explore so I don't think
there's an easy answer to that so I just
italicized your question but in some
ways some of the candidates are to the
right of the church but there is within
Mormonism Mormon culture partly because
of the missionary experience of the
world as they send Mormon family send
their young people out around the globe
and they come back a awakened and more
sympathetic than they left to the
integrity of these cultures that they
come back sometimes and marry someone in
the area that they proselytized in so
there's a grassroots part born of
experience and then there's a top-down
part by abstract principles of the
gospel equality of all people I cited an
example from the book of mormon of
actual scriptures that like all people
dealing with all collections of
scriptures are selective but the
passages selected evolved during time
and that's in response to cultural
awakenings and political moments and
things so I don't have any synthetic
ground observation other than to say I
think your question is important and if
I were spending a little more time
painting that canvas it would have some
fracture lines around thank you all we
will reconvene at 2 45 on the dot